we're going to play a quick game of
behind the scenes we J to take a s okay
okay this first photo is from a
different world oh my goodness what do
you think when you see this picture all
I see is Willow and Jaden my my daughter
and my son they're like um that's all I
see I'm like oh my goodness Willow does
look like me a little bit she doesn't
just look like her dad what is something
that took place on that set that we
don't know about um not much it was such
a I mean it was such a family you know
they were all kind of like my my big
sisters my big brothers my uncles my
aunts because I was the youngest one I
feel like I had a lot of mentors and
consistently like consistently mentors
always looking out for me always going
uh-uh Jaya not that you know what I mean
because I was I was a wild child you
certainly were which why I was like oh I
know you you I didn't know this about
you y Yum Yum Yum y I was a wild child
okay the next photo oh my God my
favorite movie I just watched it for the
40th time the other night girls trips oh
my God come on give me something I love
that movie so much yeah we had a good
time on that movie I would say we did a
lot of improving we did a lot of
improving on that movie and it would
always be jumped off by Tiffany Tiffany
was always coming up with something wild
to do in the scene and we would play off
of her do you think there'll be a girl
trip too I mean look they keep talking
about it so we'll see need it please I
mean it would be lovely to do it'd be
lovely to do need it my
[Music]
love